si lo reporta este jueves la cifra más
alta de contagios en toda la historia de
la pandemia por encima de los 7 mil 800
casos y la segunda más alta de
fallecidos 193 personas en las últimas
24 horas lo que eleva el total a más de
23 mil en un día en que se supera
también la barrera psicológica del
millón de contagiados desde el inicio de
la pandemia el gobierno endurece las
medidas cierran las fronteras
por ejemplo el aeropuerto arturo benítez
de santiago no podrá recibir extranjeros
durante al menos el mes de abril se
adelanta al toque de queda y se revisan
los permisos esenciales en un intento
por frenar la movilidad cuando ya 16 de
los 19 millones de chilenos es decir un
84 por ciento de la población se
encuentra bajo confinamiento total
aunque uno no lo diría viendo el
tránsito de vehículos en esta zona del
centro de la capital que se encuentra
también confinada la campaña de
vacunación de chiles sigue avanzando a
un ritmo veloz con más de 36% de los
chilenos que han recibido una primera
dosis y casi un 20 por ciento de ellos
que han recibido una vacunación una
inoculación completa sin embargo
tardarán todavía en sentirse en las
cifras de contagios y también en los
ingresos hospitalarios
cuando las unidades de cuidados
intensivos ya se encuentran ocupadas en
un preocupante 96% en una semana en que
el instituto de salud pública confirmó
la transmisión comunitaria de dos de las
variantes del virus consideradas más
peligrosas la brasileña y la británica